debate night it's the most wondrous of
night
it's a magical night and I don't know we
don't have it we don't have an intro uh
we don't debate night uh don't get the
wrong idea we're never going daily
that's that's not what this is about but
it is the debates and we get a lot of
people who tune in to our live streaming
so we figured okay tonight let's let's
provide you with some live streaming I
know I don't uh I didn't have cable for
a long time until we had to bundle it
for premium internet so uh for those out
there who don't we're going to live
stream the debates we will provide our
commentary here tonight we have a
drinking game
um you can read the rules
in the YouTube description or those on
Facebook the Facebook description or
ar15.com arfcom uh anytime Donald Trump
says truthfully frankly honestly or let
me tell you drink anytime he says okay
half sip or rehydrate with water we
don't want any lawsuits anytime Hillary
Clinton coughs wheezes sneezes or looks
of General ill health drink anytime she
accuses Donald Trump or Republicans of
being racist sexist Prejudice xenophobic
uh half super Hydra we again we don't
want any lawsuits so these are the rules
but you can draw your own conclusions
also In fairness this could be cut out
any moment now we just don't know the
stream the stream we just could cut out
at any moment because it's not fair use
apparently apparently public uh
presidential debates uh to provide
commentary so we do have our our adult
beverages going here there's no FCC
unlike ladder with crudder on the uh on
the Thursdays but did you check with
YouTube they could have their own uh
they could have their own they could
demonetize it you were drinking a coffee
beer that's what this says what do we
have Founders not get Jared picked it up
you got a fruit beer I'd crucify him uh
it's a it's a Paleo but it's not a stout
but brewed with
um light roasted coffee it's good pale
ale good very nice I don't know if
that's cheating because technically
there could be some caffeine in there
what do you think is going to happen
tonight with the debate but by the way
first off fair warning if you're looking
for cheerleading if you're looking for
people who are in the tank for someone
or just oh Trump's gonna this is not the
stream for you okay we're going to just
watch it call it as we see it
um good or bad on either side okay
because I've seen all these other
channels on there you know they're going
like oh man it shouldn't even allow this
to happen out of Ethics uh Trump's gonna
destroy Hillary Clinton honestly I think
she's probably going to have a pretty
good showing but Donald Trump doesn't
need a great showing he just needs to to
not lay an egg what do you what do you
think we should expect tonight I'm just
I I honestly have no idea what to expect
we've been looking for this night we
talked about it for for months out I
mean even last year I think we people
had speculated it could end up Trump
Hillary who knows yeah so a long time
coming I don't know what to expect I'm
curious to see which Trump shows up is
this I just sent you my screen by the
way you did yeah I just I realized I've
got it you got it yeah I do have it okay
so we're going to be tweeting tweets and
stuff yeah so I just want to see which
which Trump shows up to this tonight I
think Hillary Clinton is going to be
very well prepared I think she's
probably going to uh try and remain on
on policy I think she's probably trying
to she'll try to remain substantive
um and I think Donald Trump I don't know
how Donald Trump's going to do he's
never really had a one-on-one format
where it's hey you've got a couple
minutes go you know the sound bites
actually work in his favor when there
were 19
000 people on the stage but uh in a
one-on-one it's a it's kind of
difference between a short video and a
podcast that said compared to the
primaries where you know the attacks
were all you know he's not real
conservative this and that
none of those cards on the table for
Hillary tonight she can't play any of
them it's true they all work they make
her make him a better candidate to her
crowd except he doesn't he's not going
to get any Democrats he needs to get
more of the Republican base he doesn't
have enough approval yet there are some
Republicans who still have until
election night for him to prove it to
them so uh there are a lot of you know
debates don't usually settle anything
let me know when they're bringing them
out uh debates don't usually settle
anything the difference here is they're
both so unlikable and there are so many
people who are undecided and it's so
close and nothing's been predictable so
it's anybody's ball game at this point
typically people again who are in the
tank for Trump are going to say he
destroyed her no matter what people who
can't stand Trump are going to say he's
a racist and he sucks no matter what so
uh we'll try not to do that uh obviously
I like to see points scored on Hillary
Clinton because it's fun but uh I don't
know sometimes it's by the way Lester
Holt I was hearing as a republican
that's the same rumor I heard as well
I'm not even convinced he's black no
that's up for question two that's a guy
who walks into Brooks Brothers and it's
a betting pool as to where he's from
it's that kind of guy Lester Holt yeah
what do you think he is do you think
he's
you think he's playing racial I don't
know an old Japanese in there no one
knows I don't think anyone's thinking
Japanese uh let me look on the Twitter
here let me see what we got going on
people are uh tweeting a bunch live
stream live stream live stream come take
it I dare you I don't even know what
that means uh is there an S crowd or IRC
chat anywhere from base citizen yeah
it's Twitter you should make chat open
more fun for all
um listen YouTube just evolves
really quickly Twitter allows you to
stay in direct communication plus it
doesn't slow down the stream as much
considering we have so Hey look it's
Shep Smith I always think that guy looks
like a catfish with AIDS yeah
you mean like a catfish like you got on
the line you're like hey I got a catfish
it's got eight
that's that's the chef face
rumors it's a cafe as well uh with uh
yeah but for those if you haven't
figured out we're watching the uh the
Fox News version on on because the scene
I won't cut out because it was somebody
illegitimately uh just streaming it as
is no commentary and they were they were
um quickly
swifted into a dark dungeon some people
are saying way more fun with the chat
turned on we want to turn the chat on
can we do it once it started yeah I
think so I mean well here's the thing
you can go in the chat things can get
crazy we're not going to be able to read
it we're reading Twitter so if you want
to get to us go in on Twitter we have
too many things going on right now but
if you want to you I don't care enable
the chat that's fine all right it
doesn't really serve a purpose with the
with the show oh my Lord people are
saying some weird stuff really all right
I wouldn't be surprised no uh your feed
froze yes I'm watching live stream on
escrow seems pretty hardcore does root
beer account no it does not Trump will
win crowd or stop being a Negative Nancy
American Bob you should leave
trip will win
Joe's how don't blow his mind at oh that
liberals think you are he may lose he
may win he may lose you gotta go in and
accept be at point zero
he may win he may lose that's one thing
like he it could go either way
um
they're very low expectations for Trump
too they've been setting that this week
you know other than saying he hasn't
been preparing at all and Hillary is
hyper preparing so it's supposed to be
kind of this whole laid-back Trump
versus Hillary who's they're going to
try and make her look robotic in
staccato yeah and I'm not even saying
that that's not accurate uh did the
stream go out again well I'm just
checking checking to see if there's well
we have Mrs Crowder who may or may not
come in uh later on for future debates
by the way we will have lines open uh we
don't have it now because we're updating
our whole systems and moving stuff over
but hashtag never daily uh do you
remember the rules not gay Jared I do
because I wrote them down and they are
presently in front of me that's the only
reason I remember we could watch the NBC
version two here a couple different ones
we can oh Lord Chuck Todd
time has not been good to that guy it it
looks like um
like if a caterpillar crawled on his
face and died but if the caterpillar had
a wig of pubes
that's fair like you know like just
picture like a caterpillar like in a
public stall and it dragged through the
pubic hair and then crawled are people
seeing me doing this I can't see I'm
only seeing the feet that's Chuck Todd I
know people going why is this listen
we're just waiting here we're killing
time okay there's Lester Holt
doing his luster Holt stuff he couldn't
do a cartoon like Lester Holt
no it would be considered too
unrealistic okay is he given the rules
here
all right tonight is divided into six
segments each 15 minutes long we'll
explore three topic areas tonight
achieving Prosperity America's Direction
and stream is shut down shut down right
away NBC starting each segment now he's
ABC though right Lester Holt
I think he is it's nice to see them all
coming together to try and elect Hillary
it's inspiring if they have ever seen
something someone said Facebook feed is
broken I don't think it's broken I think
their stuff is broken are you guys
playing the drinking game yes we are yes
we are
however at this moment as we welcome the
candidates what democratic nominee oh
we're a little late I guess the stream's
a little late Hillary stop ruining it
for us
my wife's ruining it right okay there
comes Hillary Clinton oh God she went
with the Kim Jong-un look oh Lord
Hillary went with a Kim Jong-un look
[Applause]
if Kim Jong-un was shot and was bleeding
out in the ICU he'd look like Hillary
Clinton
she has the same body shape as Kim
Jong-un too that's just not just she
does my mom's a wardrobe stylist this is
a great example she needs someone to
tell her like hey I get you like those
suits but those aren't the right what
kind of hell for you what kind of golfer
do you think she is though maybe yacht
racer
I don't know that she can move her hips
to go so many of the issues that voters
all right let's see what these first
questions are this is weird
but this evening belongs to the
candidates and just as important to the
American people oh right away right away
resting face
so let's begin
segment achieving Prosperity achieving
Prosperity Hillary Clinton I just got a
Goldman Sachs
America today give a speech six straight
years kill a guy and new senses
after years of stagnation however income
inequality remains significant and
nearly half of Americans are living
paycheck to paycheck beginning with you
secretary uh Clinton by the way income
inequality but we've talked about that
in a recent podcast let me let her
answer and we'll come back in here
American workers
Lester and thanks to Hofstra for hosting
us did you hear the issue trigger
warnings questions yeah and created a
safe space for the debate what kind of
country we want to be and what kind of
future we'll Build Together
today is my granddaughter's second
birthday so I think about this a lot
first we have to build an economy that
works for everyone not just those at the
top not just me we need new jobs she
hasn't been on top in years I want us to
invest in you I want us to invest in
your future that means jobs and
infrastructure in advance Manufacturing
in Invasion and Technology clean
renewable energy and small business
because most of the new jobs will come
from small business
we also have to make the economy did you
see that she raises from billionaires
like 20 to 1 to Donald Trump oh really
yes small business they don't like
Democrats small bundle business they
typically vote Republican big business
they hedge their Bets with Democrats
people don't understand that because you
need big government for big business
Hillary Clinton
you should no one's buying this she is
the Buddy of a big business
and I want us to do more to support
people who I've got to say she looks
more refreshed than she has in recent
weeks well that's the Botox and uh about
the difficult choices you face
morticians
have a Paid Family Leave earn sick days
let's be sure we have affordable child
care and debt-free college paid family
leave is it no longer maternity they
want to they want to pass I wanna down
to guys and close
close the corporate loopholes it'll
allow me to raise Millions
from the big Banks she doesn't mean that
uh Donald
it's good to be with you
we're going to have a debate where we
are talking about the important issues
facing our country you have to judge us
who can shoulder the immense awesome
responsibilities of the presidency so
once again you turn up the debate volume
to action the plans it will make is that
better for you Taylor McPherson I hope
that I will be able to earn your vote on
November 8th
secretary Clinton thank you Mr Trump the
same question to you it's about putting
money more money into the pockets of
American workers you have up to two
minutes thank you Lester our jobs are
fleeing the country
they're going to Mexico they're going to
many other countries you look at what
China is doing to our country oh China
product we almost put that in the
drinking game doing their currency and
there's nobody in our government to
fight them and it's lost very good fight
and we have a winning fight because
they're using our country as a piggy
bank to rebuild China and many other
countries are doing the same thing so
we're losing our good job so many of
them when you look at what's happening
in Mexico a friend of mine who builds
plants said it's the eighth wonder of
the world they're building some of the
biggest plants anywhere in the world
some of the most sophisticated some of
the best plants with the United States
as he said not so much so Ford is
leaving you see that their small car
division leaving thousands of jobs
leaving Michigan leaving Ohio they
should leave and they should leave with
the UAW they should leave in the state
that spled them dry it's not pro-america
from what you're gonna force them to
stay disagree a little bit bit as to
numbers and amounts and what we're going
to do but perhaps we'll be talking about
that later but we have to stop our jobs
from being stolen from us we have to
stop our companies from leaving the
United States and with it firing all of
their people all you have to do is take
a look at Carrier air conditioning in
Indianapolis they left fired 1400 people
they're going to Mexico
that that split screen not let it happen
my plan I'll be reducing taxes
tremendously from 35 percent to 15
percent for companies small and big
businesses that's going to be a job
Creator like we haven't seen since
Ronald Reagan it's going to be a
beautiful thing to watch companies Will
Come Donald Trump they will expand new
companies will start and I look very
very much forward to doing it we have to
read the other way around
and we have to Ronald Reagan wasn't very
fond of Trump no Trump wasn't Ronald
Reagan but then again they supported
then he tried to Buddy Upton the second
time Second Time Around trade is an
important issue of course we are five
percent of the world's population wasn't
a bad opening trip with the other 95 and
we need to have Smart fair trade deals
we also though so she supported TPP
until she was against it and not just
Financial transactions and the kind of
plan that Donald has put forth and a tax
system that rewards is to punish people
for working more the most extreme
version the biggest tax cuts for uh the
top percents of the people in this
country than we've ever
do we lose a stream damn it uh we just
got to refresh it that's one of the
biggest myths by the way you want to
know top five percent if you're earning
210 000 about I was just looking at the
U.S Census Bureau today so you need to
know the numbers you're defining you
want to raise taxes on families earning
200 000. let's be clear about that and
Rising incomes I think we come at it
from somewhat different perspectives uh
I understand that you know Donald uh was
very fortunate in his life and that's
all to his benefit uh he started his
business with 14 million dollars
borrowed from his father and he really
believes that the more you help wealthy
people the better off we'll be and that
everything will work out from there I
don't buy that
and took the squeegee G and kept going
and so what I believe is the more we can
do for the middle class the more we can
invest in you your education yourself or
you haven't met you in several decades
you will be off and the better will grow
that's the kind of economy I want us to
see again let me follow up with Mr Trump
if I can you've talked about creating 25
million jobs and you promised to bring
bring back millions of jobs for
Americans how are you going to bring
back the industries that have left this
country for cheaper labor overseas how
specifically are you
tell American manufacturers that you
have to come back well for one thing
stream is up Austin that my father gave
me a very small loan in 1975 and I built
it into a company that's worth many many
billions of dollars
several million is not a small loan I'd
just rather just shoot it straight just
say hey yeah you know what listen I got
millions of dollars and I turn it into
more money
don't let her hang you on that Don
evaluate and all of these countries all
over the world especially China There
You Go China all these countries thus
far has only been China in Mexico all
these Cuts all these countries
Lithuania can you oh China negotiate our
trade deals unless you're they're taking
our jobs they're giving incentives
they're doing things that frankly we
don't do let me give you the example of
Mexico they have a vat tax we're in a
different system when we sell into
Mexico for those who don't know
they sell in automatic 16 approximately
when they sell into us there's no tax
it's a defective agreement it's been
defective for a long time many years but
the politicians haven't done anything
about it now in all fairness to
secretary Clinton
yes is that okay good I want you to be
very happy
it's very important to me but in all
fairness to secretary Clinton what when
she started the hell was that about this
it was really very recently she's been
doing this for 30 years
and why hasn't she made the agreements
better the NAFTA agreement say what's
good for Hillary because of the taxes
that Donald Trump is because of the fact
because she looks up secretary Clinton
and that's what they coach you to do
when you have turkey neck like that
anyway so I look up a little bit so it's
a natural because of the fact that
defense mechanism with the camera for
Hillary like look see if she's looking
down at Donald but she's looking up so
all this pneumonia tissue her goiter we
cannot do it any longer back to the
question though how do you bring back
specifically bring back jobs American
manufacturers how do you make them bring
the jobs back well the first thing you
do is don't let the jobs leave the
companies are leaving I could name I
mean they're how do you not let
companies and they're leaving in bigger
numbers than ever
you want to go to Mexico or some other
country good luck we wish you a lot of
luck but if you think you're going to
make your air conditioners or your cars
or your cookies or whatever you make to
bring them into our country without a
tax you're wrong and once you say you're
going to have to tax them coming in and
our politicians never do this because
they have special interests and the
special interests want those companies
to leave because in many cases they own
the companies so what I'm saying is we
can stop them from leaving we have to
stop them from leaving and that's a big
big factor let me let secretary Clinton
I know that sounds good but everyone out
there watching this computer phone you
can expect a a cost skyrocketing 25 50
200 on all goods and services all of you
do better
when businesses are allowed to create a
more business friendly environment and
sometimes there are Source materials
that just can't be found in the United
States failed so I'd rather instead of
taxes and tariffs start off with
creating a business friendly environment
in the United States start off by
lowering the highest corporate tax rates
start off with tax incentives not
punishment back in 2006. gee I I hope it
does collapse because then I can go in
and buy some and make some money well it
did collapse that's called business but
nine million people nine million people
lost their jobs 5 million people lost
their homes and 13 trillion dollars in
family wealth was wiped out now I'm
checking Twitter you have come back from
that abyss and it has not been easy so
we're now on the precipice of having a
potentially much better economy but the
last thing we need to do is to go back
to the policies that failed Us in the
first place
independent experts have looked at what
I've proposed and looked at what
Donald's proposed
two of which were completely unfettered
by democrats five trillion I don't I
don't know whether it's not those
policies
middle class families compared to the
wealthy were to go into effect we would
lose three and a half million jobs
and maybe have another recession they've
looked at my plans and they've said okay
if we can do this and I intend to get it
done we will have a million more new
jobs because we will be making
Investments where we can grow your ears
Donald thinks that climate change is a
hoax perpetrated by the Chinese I think
it's real I did not oh come on oh come
on you never said it's perpetrated by
the Chinese he said a lot of things are
perpetrated by the Chinese
energy
we can build a new modern electric grid
that's a lot of jobs that's a lot of new
economic activity here's one thing they
don't talk about nearly all of the job
growth under Obama the biggest the
biggest job Creator was fracking which
they fought
and it's also why we have more oil than
ever by the way we've talked about this
no longer a thing because of fracking we
have more oil than ever and I mean than
ever not more than we thought we have
access to more oil than ever we invested
and they fought it and oil is less
expensive it's more affordable than ever
on that one now look I'm a great
believer in all forms of energy but
we're putting a lot of people out of
work our energy policies are a disaster
our country is losing so much in terms
of energy in terms of paying off our
debt you can't do what you're looking to
do with 20 trillion in debt the Obama
Administration from the time they've
come in is over 230 years worth of debt
and he's topped it he's doubled it in a
the course of almost eight months when
she lies I don't know if we can handle
that so I will tell you this I think
people are just going to be it's going
to be alcohol poisoning at keeping our
jobs and we have to do a much better job
at giving companies incentive to build
new companies or to expand because
they're doing it and all you have to do
is look at Michigan and look at Ohio and
look at all Michigan is a crap hole
Detroit deserves to die this is that
Republican pandering companies when
they're living it up on Wall Street
they're shutting Detroit down they
should shut both down both of them both
like this for 30 years why are you just
thinking about these Solutions right now
for 30 years you've been doing it and
now you're just starting to think of
solutions well I will bring excuse me I
will bring back jobs
I have thought about this quite a bit
yeah for 30 years
well not quite that long uh did a good
job in the 1990s I think a lot about
what worked and how we can make it work
again
which is the single worst trade deal
s went up for everybody Manufacturing
so in the 1990s if we're actually going
to look at the facts who cares
the number of technical jails that came
in there for me and I helped them all
there's plenty of manufacturing this
idea that only manufacturing jobs count
is silly and that's the pandering that
happens and that's Donald Trump trying
to solidify Michigan Pennsylvania
Michigan but the Rust Belt because it's
all about Union entitlements they vote
in their own self-interest listen
hopefully get your manufacturing job but
I care about an honest economy that's
business friendly that's not
if other skilled trades for college
educated people become available an
increasing amount and Manufacturing is
less guess what I'm okay with that too
we all should be trying to enforce the
trade deals we have and we're going to
hold people accountable when I was
Secretary of State we actually increased
American exports globally the sound
that's actually them in China
get new jobs and to get exports that
help to create eight more new jobs Eric
well you haven't done it in 30 years or
26 years I've been a senator you haven't
done it I have benefited State and I
have your husband's side laughter
Stephen find out where Clinton winning
Pennsylvania
whatever you want secretary Clinton and
you will see Devastation where
manufacturers down 30 40 sometimes 50
percent NAFTA is the worst trade deal
maybe ever signed anywhere but certainly
ever signed in this it's smart for him
to go after him you want to approve you
know he's trying to get Pennsylvania
then you heard what I was saying how bad
it is and you said I can't win that
debate but you know that if you did win
you would approve that and that will be
almost as bad as NAFTA nothing will ever
top NAFTA that that is just not accurate
I was against it once it was finally
negotiated and the terms were laid out I
wrote about that in you called it the
gold state
he said it's the finest deal you've ever
seen no and then you heard what I said
about it and all of a sudden you were
against it well Donald I know you live
in your own reality but that is not the
facts the facts are I did say I hoped it
would be a good deal but when it was
negotiated which I was not responsible
for I concluded it wasn't I wrote about
that so is it President Obama's fault is
it president
announced Hillary Secretary
because he's pushing there are different
views about what's good for our country
our economy and our smart of trump to
get her to throw Obama I think it's
important that's a smart maneuver we
need to do to get the economy going
again that's why I said new jobs with
Rising incomes Investments not in more
tax cuts that would add five trillion
dollars to the debt but you have no plan
educate oh I do in fact you have no plan
a book about it what do you think it's
just playing well
he's going after issues sustainable grow
which is something
primary families debates we haven't seen
the responsibilities at home and the
responsibilities at business so we have
a very robust set of plans and people
who have looked at both of our plans
have concluded that mine would create 10
million jobs and yours would lose us
three and a half million jobs and expect
you are going to approve one of the
biggest taxes in history you are going
to approve one of the biggest tax
increases in history you are going to
teach yourself check this out your
regulations are a disaster and you're
going to increase regulations all over
the place and by the way my tax cut is
the biggest since Ronald Reagan I'm very
proud of it it will create tremendous
numbers of new jobs but regulations you
are going to regulate these businesses
out of existence when I go around Lester
I tell you this I've been all over and
when I go around drinkers let me tell
you the things that businesses and
people like the most is the fact that
I'm cutting regulation you have
regulations on top of regulations and
new companies cannot form and old
companies are going out of business and
you want to increase the regulations and
make them even worse I'm going to cut
regulations but I'm going to cut taxes
big league and you're going to raise
taxes Big League end of story let me get
you to pause right there because we're
going to move it we're going to move
into the next segment that can't be left
take 30 seconds I kind of assumed that
there would be a lot of these charges
and claims and so we have taken uh the
home page of my website
hillaryclinton.com and we've turned it
into a fact Checker so if you want to
see it in real time that's a smart move
what the facts are please go and take a
look you
benefits
right now going hey how is that one
alive
ah Wikipedia
regulations and streamline them for
small businesses oh shut up you can't do
that you can't do it for small
businesses you either do it you're
either business friendly or you're not
the wealthy because they have made all
the gains in the economy all the days
she was against the gays in the economy
until she was four of them
[Laughter]
she's going to raise taxes 1.3 trillion
dollars and look at her website you know
what it's no different than this she's
telling us how to fight Isis just go to
our website she tells you how to fight
Isis on her website I don't think
general Douglas MacArthur would like
that too much
the next segment will continue on the
subject
no no you're telling the enemy
everything you want to do no we're not
see you're telling the enemy everything
you want to do no wonder you've been
fighting no wonder you've been fighting
Isis your entire adult life
go to the please the fact Checkers you
are unpacking a lot here and we're still
in the issue
wildly untrue but very funny very funny
between the two of you concerns the
wealthy secretary Clinton you're calling
foreign
well I'm really calling for major jobs
because the wealthy are going to create
tremendous jobs they're going to expand
their companies they're going to do a
tremendous job I'm getting rid of the
carried interest provision and if you
really look it's not a taxation
put billions and billions of dollars
into companies
damn it NBC we have a good round trip on
our internet
we do but we have Comcast they're
screwing themselves back from overseas
where they can't bring the money back
because politicians like secretary
Clinton won't allow them to bring the
money back because the taxes are so
onerous and the bureaucratic red tape so
what is so bad so what they're doing is
they're leaving our country and they're
believe it or not leaving because taxes
are too high and because some of them
have lots of money outside of our
country and instead of bringing it back
and putting the money to work because
they can't work out a deal to and
everybody agrees it should be brought
back instead of that they're leaving our
country to get their money because they
can't bring their money back into our
country because of bureaucratic red tape
because they can't get together because
we have a PR we have a president that
generally Trump's website is down and
get them to approve something and here's
the thing Republicans and Democrats
agree that this should be done two and a
half trillion I happen to think it's
double that's probably five trillion
dollars that we can't bring into our
country Lester and with a little
leadership you'd get it in here very
quickly and it could be put to use on
the inner cities and lots of other
things and it would be beautiful but we
have no leadership and honestly that
starts with secretary Clinton all right
you have two minutes of the same
question to defend tax increases on the
wealthiest American Secretary Clinton I
have a feeling that by the end of this
evening I'm going to be blamed for
everything that's ever happened why not
why
you know just just join uh join the
debate by uh saying more crazy things
now let me say this is
letting our companies bring their money
back into this country this is uh
secretary Clinton's two minutes yes
please okay well let's start the clock
again Lester
um
we've looked at your I'll pay you for it
later posies I don't see changes in the
corporate taxes I hear you like them
thick correct kinds of proposals you're
referring to it's used but low miles
repatriation bringing back of money
that's stranded overseas I happen to
then you didn't read it I happen to I
happen to support that in a way that
will actually work to our benefit
but when I look at what you have
proposed you have
what is called now the Trump loophole
because it would so Advantage you and
the business you do you've proposed an
approaches
what is that and when you close it up
it is as I said trumped up trickle down
trickle down did not work ah the
buzzword doesn't work
we were in in 2008 and nine slashing
time and the wealthy hasn't worked
really smart wealthy people know that
and they are saying hey we need to do
more to make the contributions we should
be making to rebuild the middle class I
don't think top-down Works in America I
think building the middle class
investing you really don't want your top
down right where it is so more young
people can get their education helping
people refinance their tax their their
debt from college at a lower
four people at the very top
Mr Trump typical politician all talk no
action sounds good doesn't work never
gonna happen our country is suffering
because people like secretary he's going
to lose the election have made such a
bad decisions in terms of our jobs and
in terms of what she's not aware of what
she's working with I'm surprised Revival
of an economy he's doing really well the
Great Depression and believe me we're in
a bubble right now and the only thing
that looks good is the stock market but
if you raise interest rates even a
little bit that's going to come crashing
down we are in a big fat ugly bubble and
we better be awfully careful and we have
a fed that's doing political things this
Janet Yellen extreme quality is better
than fox is doing political by keeping
the interest rates at this level and
believe me the day Obama goes off and he
leaves and he goes out to the golf
course for the rest of his life to play
golf when they raise interest rates
you're going to see some very bad things
happen because the Fed that is not doing
their job the FED is being more
political than secretary Clinton Mr
Trump we're talking about the burden
that Americans have to pay yet you have
not released your tax returns and the
reason nominees have released their
returns for decades is that voters will
know if their potential president
Americans have a right to know if there
are any conflicts of interesting I'm
under a roots and it'll be released and
as soon as the audit's finished it'll be
released but you will learn more about
Donald Trump by going down to the
federal elections where I filed a 104
page essentially financial statement of
sorts the forms that they have he has
nothing against
no there's no good way for Donald Trump
to release things is filed at 694
million dollars for this past year 694
million if you would have told me I was
going to make that
Trump so far thumbs up or thumbs down
thumbs up
that's doing so badly that's being
ripped off by every single country China
and Mexico it's the kind of thinking
that our country needs because everybody
Lester we have a trade deficit with all
of the countries that we do business
with of almost 800 billion dollars a
year you know what that is that means
who's negotiating these trade deals we
have people that are political hacks
negotiating our trade the IRS says with
two of your taxes will be perfectly free
to release your taxes during an audit
and so the question does the Public's
right to know anywhere well I told you I
will release them as soon as the audit
look I've been on their audit almost for
15 years everyone should be disappointed
50 people that have never seen anything
almost every year and in a way I should
be complaining I'm not even complaining
I don't mind it it's almost become a way
of life I get audited by the IRS but
other people don't I will say this we
have a situation in this country that
has to be taken care of I will release
my tax returns against my lawyers wishes
when she releases her 33 000 emails that
have been deleted as soon as she
releases them
I will release my tax returns and that's
against my lawyers they say don't do it
I will tell you this no in fact watching
shows I wouldn't be surprised if Donald
Trump says this is lawyers
when the order is complete I'll do it
but I would go against them if she
releases so it's negotiable
it's not negotiable no let her release
the evil why did she delete 33 000. I'll
let her ask that but let me just started
there was an agreements
dirty little interns.com newsletter bait
and switch here and My Fit Tea for 40
years everyone running for president has
released their tax returns you can go
and see nearly I think 39 40 Years of
our tax returns but everyone has done we
know
there is no prohibitions why
won't he release his tax returns and I
think there are maybe a couple of
medicines first maybe he's not as rich
as he says he is
second maybe he's not as charitable as
he claims to be
third we don't know all of his business
dealings but we have been told through
investigative reporting that he owes
about 650 million dollars to Wall Street
and foreign Banks or is she really going
to use the Wall Street all of you
watching she went there you are knocking
at the gates of hell sweetheart in
federal taxes because the only years
that anybody's ever seen were a couple
of years when he had to turn them over
to State authorities when he was trying
to get a casino license and they showed
he didn't pay any federal income tax so
that makes me smart zero that means zero
for troops zero for vets zero for
schools or health
and I think probably he's not all that
enthusiastic about having the rest of
our country see what the real reasons
are because it must be something really
important even terrible that he's trying
to hide and the financial disclosure
statement they don't give you the taxes
all the details the tax returns right
downstairs and it just seems to me that
my wife
and people deserve to see she's getting
very personal reason to believe that and
he's holding her feet to the fire and
the issues that's the reverse that's a
little bit of a surprise reversal thing
he's hiding to support him more if I
didn't know that he was going to
guarantee to audit us for doing silly
impressions
I'm so conflicted yeah all the people in
this cabinet hate us for jokes would be
those conflicts who does he owe money to
well he owes you the answers to that and
he should provide them he also he also
raised the issue of Europe so clever I
do you know I made a mistake using a
private email that's for sure and if I
had to do it over again I would
obviously do it differently
um but I'm not going to make any excuses
it was a mistake and I take
responsibility yeah nothing between
nothing between the two firms Zach
Galifianakis can't fix
that was done purposely okay that was
not a mistake that was done purposely
when you have your staff
taking the Fifth Amendment taking the
fifth so we're not prosecuted when you
have the man that set up the illegal
server take in the fifth
I think it's disgraceful and believe me
this country thinks it's this great it
really thinks it's disgraceful also tax
returns
you don't learn that much from tax
returns that I can tell you you learn a
lot from Financial disclosure and you
should go down and take a look at that
the other thing I'm extremely under
leveraged the report that said 650 which
by the way a lot of friends of mine that
know my business said boy that's really
not a lot of money it's not a lot of
money relative to where I had the
buildings that were in question they
said in the same report which was
actually wasn't even a bad story to be
honest with you but the buildings are
worth 3.9 billion and the 650 isn't even
on that but it's not 650 it's much less
than that but I could give you a list of
banks I would if that would help you I
would give you a list of banks these are
very fine institutions very fine Banks I
could do that very quickly I am very
under leverage because people will ask
them I have a tremendous amount if he
doesn't do it he said I say that is not
that's the kind of stuff in the corner
that this country had somebody running
it that has an idea about money well we
have twenty
Monday you know it's one thing to have
20 trillion in debt and our roads are
good and our bridges are good and
everything's in great
it's like from a third world country you
landed LaGuardia
Newark and you come in from Dubai and
Qatar and you see this incredible you're
coming from China
[Music]
we owed 20 trillion dollars and we're a
mess we haven't even started and we've
spent six trillion dollars in the Middle
East according to a report that I just
saw whether it's six or five but it
looks like it's six six trillion dollars
in the Middle East we could have rebuilt
our country twice and it's really a
shame and it's politicians like
secretary Clinton that have caused this
problem our country has tremendous
problems we're a debtor Nation we're a
serious debtor nation and we have a
country that needs New Roads new tunnels
new Bridges
she's in the red he's got the blue team
we don't have the money because it's
been squandered on so many of your ideas
you haven't paid any federal income tax
for a lot of years and the other thing I
think is important it would be
squandered too believe me or if your
main claim to be president of the United
States is your business then I think we
should talk about that the main claim is
you killed Four Guys manager said that
just to be fair that's harder than it
seems businesses on the backs of little
guys
and indeed I have met a lot of the
people who were stupid
Hey Hillary no click dishwashers
painters architects
Glass installers marble installers
drapery installers like my dad 42 votes
in the country guy named Luigi is Lane
marbles she's just a lack of me ask them
to do it in the audience who designed
one of your clubhouses at one of your
golf courses
it's a beautiful facility it immediately
was put to use Hillary's gonna have to
use it
the man needed to be paid what he was
charging maybe he didn't do a good job
and I was unsatisfied with his work
but that's what needs to happen in
Michigan Donald with the unions and the
cards and GM people are unsatisfied with
American cars let's not punish the
companies for trying to improve apology
and then refused to pay them I can only
say that I'm certainly relieved that my
late father never did business with you
uh he provided a good middle class life
for us but the people he worked for he
expected the bargain to be kept on both
sides how do you feel about racing
you've taken business bankruptcy six
times
there are a lot of great business people
that have never taken bankruptcy once
you call yourself the king of death you
talk about leverage you even at one time
interested that you would try to
negotiate down the national debt of the
United States well sometimes there's not
a direct transfer she's not fluent
enough skills from business
sometimes what happens
look it's all words it's all sound bites
I built an unbelievable company some of
the greatest assets anywhere in the
world actually I do think Donald Trump
has made more money off of the United
States in Europe different places in
real estate so yeah let's talk about
cash flow but Mark Cuban's probably
right Hillary Clinton probably has more
cash than Donald Trump doesn't mean he's
not a good businessman but that's why
Hillary Clinton is willing secretary
Clinton's about people that didn't get
but taking advantage of the laws of the
nation now if you want to change the
laws you've been there a long time
change the laws but I take advantage of
the laws of the nation because I'm
running a company my obligation right
now is to do well for myself my family
my employees for my companies and that's
what I do but what you can still do that
is the tens of thousands of people that
are doing it the right unbelievably
happy and that love me I'm not saying
Trump hasn't but I think he would do
better to talk about that and the people
he's helped and the judges created them
taking advantage of the laws I don't
think that'll play well I'm going to get
to Pennsylvania
but we're opening the Old Post Office
under budget ahead of schedule saved
tremendous money I'm a year ahead of
schedule and that's what this country
should be doing one thing my beard line
looks fantastic
products
costs that are so far above
people that know what they're doing when
we look at them the budget is bad to a
large extent
that have no idea as to what to do and
how to get this out of the screenshot
is way under budget and way ahead of
schedule and we just lost 3 000
subscribers for hours
Direction and let's start by talking
about race the sheriff of course Lester
sex relations are bad it's always about
race which is Lester much of it
Amplified by shootings of African
Americans by police
race has been a big issue in this
campaign and one of you is going to have
to bridge a very wide and bitter Gap so
how do you heal the Divide secretary
Clinton you get two minutes on this well
you're right
race
remains a significant challenge in our
country
unfortunately Ray still determines too
much often determines where people lived
this race isn't looking good for you
what kind of education in their Public
Schools they can get and yes it
determines how they're treated in the
criminal justice system
we've just seen those two tragic
yes precisely
restore trust who named you Lester white
priests and the police
we have to work to make sure that I have
some comments like why so much I'm using
the best choice techniques that's what
we told you there's no script there's no
helpline for the show it's very silly
tonight Force only and the beers are
necessary like Mead everyone should be
respected by the law and everyone should
respect the law ah right now that's not
the case in a lot of art yes I know so I
have ever since day of my campaign call
for Criminal Justice Reform I've laid
off
that I think would begin to remedy some
of the problems we have in the criminal
justice system
but we also have to recognize in
addition to the Hillary Clinton
challenges walking examples
police officers who's going to make that
argument she's the example of being
treated together unfairly well because
she's a white privileged politician
and we've got to get guns
we should not have them oh guns okay gun
epidemic is the leading cause of death
should have said pandemic American men
more than the next nine causes put
together
and we have to tackle the plague of gun
violence which is a big contributor a
lot of the problems
of the gun well first of all the bloody
River and first born of the gun a couple
of words and that's Law and Order we
need Law and Order if we don't have it
we're not going to have a country and
when I look at what's going on in
Charlotte a city I love a city where I
have Investments when I look at what's
going on throughout various parts of our
country whether it's I mean I can just
keep naming them all day long we need
Law and Order in our country and I just
got today uh the as you know the
endorsement of the Fraternal Order of
Police we just just came in we have
endorsements from I think almost every
police group very I mean a large
percentage of them in the United States
we have a situation where we have our
inner cities
African-Americans Hispanics are living
in hell
because it's so dangerous you walk down
the street you get because it's so hot
in Chicago where they live they've had
thousands of shootings thousands since
January 1st thousands of shootings I
thought it was in the hundreds and I'm
saying where is this is this a war-torn
country what are we doing and we have to
stop the violence we have to bring back
Law and Order in a place like Chicago
where please the people have been killed
thousands over the last number of years
in fact almost 4 000 have been killed
since Barack Obama became president of
four almost four thousand people to be
fair half of those were just Rahm
Emanuel poking them in the shower and
they slipped now whether or not in a
place like Chicago you do stop and frisk
which worked very well mayor Giuliani is
here worked very well in New York it
brought the crime rate way down
Democrats said it was racist away from
criminals that shouldn't be having it
like Hillary Clinton's roaming the
street and in many cases they're
illegally here illegal immigrants and
they have guns and they shoot people and
we have to be very strong and we have to
be very Vigilant we have to be we have
to know what we're doing right to do so
many things that frankly nice to do
anything we have to protect our inner
cities because
African-American communities are being
decimated by crime you're two minutes to
expire but I do want to follow up stop
and frisk was ruled unconstitutional in
New York because it it largely singled
out black and Hispanics young stupid
you're wrong uh it went here's something
too let's talk I'll talk about this
week's show who was a very again if you
want to fix this get rid of the police
unions and the quotas they have quotas
for how many civilian interactions they
have to have so guess what if you're a
police and policeman and you have to
have 10 I don't know 10 civilian
interactions that night throughout the
country they're if you're a betting man
you're just going to pick the Latino and
the black guy because they're more
likely to commit crime that's what
happens with a lot of police because the
unions put a quota on them to create
more Revenue because of Baseline
budgeting
these are people that are bad people
that shouldn't be
when you have 3 000 shootings in Chicago
from January 1st when you have 4 000
people killed in Chicago
by guns from the beginning of the
presidency of Barack Obama his hometown
you have to have stop and frisk you need
more police you need a better Community
uh you know relation you don't have good
community relations in Chicago it's
terrible I have property there it's
terrible what's going on in Chicago but
when you look in Chicago
you need better relationships I agree
with secretary Clinton on this you need
better relationships between the
communities and the police because in
some cases it's not good but you look at
Dallas where the relationships were
really studied the relationships were
really a beautiful thing and then five
police officers were killed
one night very violently
so there's some bad things going going
on some really bad things
and we need Law and Order
in the inner cities because the future
thing Donald Trump you can tell on this
what's happening doesn't really know
where he's going with it and here's the
problem with Donald Trump on these
things not saying he couldn't correct it
and get it right he hasn't thought it
through and he said something but then
he'll double down
as opposed to just and I I meant to say
this it's really unfortunate that he
paid such a dire negative picture of
black communities in our country you
know the vibrancy of the black church
the the black church that we're seeing
hot sauce hot sauce opportunities that
so many families are working yeah they
smell like pumpkin farts uh there's a
lot that's not even close I'm proud of
and we should be supporting and lifting
up now black communities always have to
make sure we keep people safe there are
the right ways of doing it and the
communities in the inner cities in
Chicago Detroit they're bad sorry
they're bad for black people found to be
unconstitutional
and I don't care if there's a nice choir
at a church
it did not do what it needed to do now I
believe in community policing little
known fact and in fact Marie Giuliani
decreasing crime in New York by so much
what it was almost single-handedly
decreased the crime rate under Clinton
to decreased crime so much in New York
City that it made Clinton look good
National 25 years of very good
cooperation but there were some problems
some unintended consequences too many
young African-American and Latino men
ended up in jail for non-violent
offenses and it's just a fact that if
you're a young African-American man and
you do the same thing as a young white
man you are more likely to be arrested
charged convicted and incarcerated so
we've got to address the systemic racism
in our Criminal Justice System we cannot
just say Law and Order we have to say we
we have to come forward with a plan that
is going to divert people from the
criminal justice system deal with
mandatory minimum sentences which have
put too many people away for too long
for doing too little we need to have
more Second Chance programs I'm glad
that we're ending private prisons in the
federal system I want to see them ended
in the state system you shouldn't have a
profit motivation to fill prison cells
with Young Americans so there are some
positive ways we can work on this and I
believe strongly that Common Sense gun
safety measures would assist us question
from
reformed along with the gun laws along
with her husband military style weapons
on the streets in a lot of places our
police are outgunned out checks
and we need to keep guns out of the
hands of those who will do harm and we
finally need to attention a Prohibition
on anyone who's on the terrorist watch
list from being able to buy a gun like
Stephen Hayes
anyone can be put on that list and
there's no recourse there's no way to
appeal last week you said we've got to
do everything possible
implicit bias do you believe that police
are implicitly biased against black
people Lester I think implicit bias is a
problem for everyone not just police
I think unfortunately too many of us in
our great country
um jump to conclusions about each other
and therefore I think we need all of us
to be asking hard questions about
you know why am I feeling this way but
when it comes to policing since it can
have literally fatal consequences I have
said in my first budget we will I was
asking yeah
to help us deal with implicit bias by
retraining a lot of our police officers
I've met with a group of very
distinguished experienced police Chiefs
a few weeks ago they admit it's an issue
they've got a lot of concerns mental
health is one of the biggest concerns
because now police are having to handle
a lot of really difficult mental health
problems on the street they want are we
supposed to believe that more people
mentally understand more assistance and
I think yeah how is that an all of a
sudden epidemic especially when mental
health
Mental Health Care should be as
efficient as ever I don't understand
that and a lot of people even within my
own party want to give certain rights to
people on watch lists and no-fly lists I
agree with you when a person is on a
watch list or in no-fly list and I have
the endorsement of the NRA which I'm
very proud
don't do this don't say the Second
Amendment but I think we have to look
very strongly at no-fly lists and watch
lists and when people are on there even
if they shouldn't be on there we'll help
them we'll help them legally we'll help
them get off but I tend to agree with
that uh quite strongly I do want to
bring up the fact that you were there
you go okay we're super Predator Dave
that's a big one young black youth and
that's a term that I think was a uh it's
hard it's been horribly met as you know
I think you've apologized for it but I
think it was a terrible thing to say and
when it comes to uh stop and frisk you
know you're talking about taking guns
away from gangs no no fly list he did
throw in there
let's cover them a little bit you don't
take someone's rights away if they're
wrong on a list you don't get to do that
you don't get to take someone's rights
away we had 2 200 murders and stop and
frisk brought it down to 500 murders 500
murders a lot of murders hard to believe
500 is like supposed to be good
but we went from 2 200 to 500 and it was
continued on by Mayor Bloomberg and it
was terminated by current mayor but stop
and fit Frisk had a tremendous impact on
the safety of New York City tremendous
beyond belief So when you say it has no
impact it really did it had a very very
big impact well it's also a lot of
people pissed on the no-fly list thing a
lot of people saying I was with him I
was with him murders so there he is
all right New York New York has John and
I give credit across the board going
back uh two Mayors two police Chiefs
because it has worked and other
communities need to come together to do
what will work as well look one murder
is too many yeah people are really mad
about it everyone is pissed about that
what has everyone is pissed about that
and not go to things that sound good
that really did not Houston Bible says
but let's also add
no one should disagree about respecting
the rights of young men who live in
those neighborhoods and so we need to do
a better job of working again with the
communities
Faith communities business communities
as well as the police to try to deal
with it first it's about race and so Mr
Trump I have to ask but I'd like to just
respond if I might please uh I'd just
like to respond please respond that I've
got to I will follow up look the
African-American Community
oh okay
[Music]
and I will tell you
you look at the inner cities and I just
left Detroit and I just left
Philadelphia and I just you know you've
seen me I've been all over the place uh
don't go there and you decided to never
get out and that's okay but I will tell
you I've been all over and I've met some
of the greatest people I'll ever meet
I think I think that I think Donald just
criticized me for preparing for this
debate
and yes I did
and you know what else I prepared for I
prepared to be president and I think
that's a good thing
Mr Trump for five years you perpetuated
a false claim of the Nations
you questioned his legitimacy in the
last question no no she did you
acknowledge what most Americans have
accepted for years the president was
born in the United States can you tell
us what took you said I'll tell you very
well just very simple to say uh
Sydney Blumenthal
works for the campaign and close very
close friend of secretary Clinton and
her
campaign manager Patty Doyle stick it
back on her went to no one he doesn't
really know somebody again
very hard very close look it up and you
can check it out and if you look at
something you sound like you're Jew in
the Hitler video
was on Wolf Blitzer saying that this
happened Blumenthal sent McClatchy
find out about it they were pressing it
very hard she failed to get the birth
certificate when I got involved I didn't
fail I got him to give
the birth certificate so I'm satisfied
with it and I'll tell you why I'm
satisfied with it because I want to get
on to defeating Isis because I want to
get on to creating jobs because I want
to get on to having a strong border
because I want to get on to things that
are very important to me and that are
very important to the country I'll let
you respond it's important but I just
want to get the answer here the birth
certificate was produced in 2011 you
continued to tell the story and question
the president's legitimacy in 2012 13 14
15 as recently as January so the
question is what changes everybody was
pressing it nobody was caring much about
it I figured you'd ask the question
tonight of course but nobody was caring
much about it but I was the one that got
him to produce the birth certificate and
I think I did a good job
secretary Clinton he didn't answer the
question though I mean you know now
everybody in mainstream is going to say
oh that's yeah that's a flub Donald if
you didn't answer it he asked a specific
question about it afterwards you just
have to take a look at CNN the last week
the interview with your former care
technology
but just like she can't bring back jobs
she can't produce I'm sorry I'm just
going to fall but I will let you respond
to that because if there's a lot there
but we're talking about racial healing
in this segment what do you say to
Americans well it was very I said No I
say nothing because I was able to get
him to produce it he should have
produced it a long time before I say
nothing but let me just tell you what is
the person we have to do with racial
healing I never understood that I think
that the question is his birth that
means you're racist would you ever say
he's born in Russia you know what I mean
it was just it just happened to me that
you know Kenya he could claimed to be
his homeland and I feel that they it's a
silly issue but it doesn't mean it's
inherently racist I've been a great
service not only for the country but
even for the president in getting him to
produce his person secretary Clinton
well just listen to what you heard
and see for those now clearly for those
of you watching who like Trump you need
to understand that can only work if you
really screwed up Donald just admitted
he knew he was going to stand on this
listen and they were asking us questions
you may not like the whole race
she's picking up Steve now
but it can't be dismissed that easily
he has really
started his political activity based on
This Racist lie that our first black
president
was not an American citizen
there was absolutely no evidence but he
persisted he persisted year after year
what do you think some of his supporters
fold apparently believed it or wanted
he's losing a little bit right now
Donald started his career back in 1973
being sued by the justice department for
racial discrimination
because he would not rent
apartments in one of his developments to
African Americans and he made sure that
the people who worked for him understood
that was the policy he actually was sued
twice by the justice department so he
has a long thanks train safe said they
liked that when we covered her face
racist Behavior here
right you know Barack Obama is a man of
dignity
or get on this real good and I could
tell how much it bothered him and
annoyed him
that this was being touted and used
against him
but I like to remember what Michelle
Obama said in her amazing speech at our
Democratic National Convention
when they go low we go high and Barack
Obama went High despite
Donald Trump's best efforts to bring him
down Mr Trump you can respond it was
pretty good it was pretty close it's
pretty good pretty good skill that's
pretty good skill useless we'll produce
zero dollars
respect and I watched the way you talk
now about how lovely everything is and
how wonderful you are basically my wife
has a good point hey Hill you're on the
mic when I go uh urinate during the
commercial print out pictures don't put
it on camera because I don't want all
the horny YouTubers you can deny that
but just last week your campaign manager
said it was true so when you try to act
holier than thou it really doesn't work
it really doesn't now as far as the
lawsuit yes when I was very young I went
into my father's company had a real
estate company in Brooklyn and Queens
people are saying just keep her face
covered many many other companies
we settled the suit with zero with no
admission of guilt it was very easy to
do but they sued many people I notice
you bring that up a lot and you know I
also noticed the very nasty commercials
that you do on me in so many different
ways which I don't do on you maybe I'm
trying to save the money but frankly
yeah frankly and I say isn't that
amazing because I settled that lawsuit
my wife my mother would be right there
against many real estate firms and it's
just one of those things I'll go on one
step further in Palm Beach Florida tough
Community a brilliant Community a
wealthy community probably the
wealthiest Community there is in the
world all right I'll be right back
sounds good and myself really got great
credit for it no discrimination against
African Americans against Muslims
against anybody and it's a tremendously
successful club and I'm so glad I did it
and
I have been given great credit for what
I did and I'm very very proud of it and
that's the way I feel that is the true
way I feel our next segment is called
securing America we want to start with a
21st century War happens in this country
our institutions are under Cyber attack
and our secrets are being stolen so my
question is who's behind us will we
fight it secretary Clinton this answer
goes to you
well I think cyber security cyber
warfare will be one of the biggest
challenges facing the next president
because clearly we're facing at this
point uh two different kinds of
adversaries there are the independent
hacking groups that do it mostly for
commercial reasons to try to steal
information that they then can use to
make money but increasingly we are
seeing cyber attacks coming from States
organs of states the most recent and
troubling of these has been Russia
there's no doubt now that Russia has
used cyber attacks against
all kinds of organizations in our
country and I am deeply concerned about
this I know Donald's very Praise
praiseworthy of uh Vladimir Putin but
Putin is playing with a really tough
long game here
is to let loose uh cyber attackers to
hack into government
files to hack into personal files hack
into the Democratic National Committee
keep the tweets going did he keep the
commentary going I was gone like three
words preferred methods of trying to
wreak havoc and collect information we
need to make it very clear weather
or anybody else the United States has
hacking hacking hacking capacity we are
not going to
but we will defend the citizens of this
country and the Russians need to
understand that I think they've been
treating it as almost a probing uh how
far would we go the only problem you've
had in years
I was so shocked when Donald publicly
invited Putin to hack into Americans
that that is is just unacceptable it's
one of the reasons why 50 National
Security officials who served in
Republican information in administration
have said that Donald is unfit to be the
commander-in-chief it's comments like
that that really worry people who
understand the threats that we Face Mr
Trump you have two minutes in the same
question I do want to say that I was
just endorsed and more are coming next
week it'll be over 200 Admirals many of
them are here generals endorsed me
everyone said you didn't say anything
while I was gone
beer that just happened while I was very
uncomfortable
in addition I was just endorsed by Ice
they've never endorsed anybody before on
immigration I was just endorsed by Ice I
was just recently endorsed sixteen
thousand five people watching the patrol
agents
secretary Clinton talks about this I
mean I'll Take 6 700. what are you doing
with your generals that
I don't think anybody knows it was
Russia that broke into the DNC she's
saying Russia Russia Russia but I don't
maybe it was I mean it could be Russia
but it could also be China
it also could be somebody throwing on
their bed that weighs 400 pounds okay
you don't know who broke in to DNC but
what would be along with DNC we learned
that Bernie Sanders
was taken advantage of by oh he's trying
to appeal to the burning voters by Deb
Wasserman Schultz look what happened to
her we want a more drunk okay Jared was
taking advantage of that news now
whether that was Russia apparently the
hardest all living for dinner is another
country guacamole because the truth is
under President
we've lost control what it's worth
that's what I eat for lunch we used to
have control over yeah
um and I think secretary this holy
guacamole
is that from Costco beating us at all
it's actually just from like uh Isis you
get to anywhere so we have to get big
guacamole
it is a huge problem I have a son he's
10 years old he has computers how the
hell does he have a 10 year old son
that's all Testament Abraham the
security aspect of cyber how does he
have a 10 year old son
Society
we have so many things that we have to
do better Lester and certainly cyber is
one of them secretary Clinton
well I think there are a number of
issues that uh we should be addressing
um I have put forth a plan to defeat
Isis uh it does involve going after them
online I think we need to do much more
with our tech companies to prevent Isis
from being able to use the internet to
radicalize even direct uh people in our
country in Europe and elsewhere but we
also have to intensify our air strikes
against Isis and eventually support our
Arab and Kurdish uh Partners to be able
to actually take out Isis uh in raqqa
and their claim of being a caliphate
we're making progress our military
Facebook's consisting in Iraq uh and
we're hoping
within the year
100 true but we have to to be cognizant
of the fact that the lavender and
foreign Fighters coming to volunteer for
them foreign money uh foreign so we have
to make this the top priority and I
would also do everything possible to
take out their leadership I was involved
in a number of efforts to take out
Al-Qaeda leadership when I was Secretary
of State including of course taking out
Bin Laden and I think we need to go
after Baghdad nothing to do with them as
well make that one of our organizing
principles because we've got to except
for her husband not doing anything about
him in the 90s do everything we can to
disrupt their uh propaganda efforts
online you mentioned Isis and we think
of Isis certainly as it would happen to
isil please give up on that
of course the bombings we just saw in
New York and New Jersey the 90s
San Bernardino and Orlando I'll ask this
to both of you tell us specifically how
you would prevent homegrown attacks
by American citizens Mr well first I
have to say one thing very important
secretary Clinton is talking about
taking out Isis we will take out Isis
well President Obama and secretary
Clinton created a vacuum the way they
got out of Iraq because they got outro
they shouldn't have been in but once
they got in the way they got out was a
disaster
and Isis was formed so she talks about
taking them out she's been doing it a
long time she's been trying to take him
out for a long time
but they wouldn't have even been formed
if they left some troops behind like 10
000 or maybe something more than that
and then you wouldn't have had them or
as I've been saying for a long time and
I think you'll agree because I said it
to you once
had we taken the oil
on Facebook ended Isis would not have
been able to form either because the oil
was their primary source of income and
now they have the oil all over the place
including the oil a lot of the oil in
Libya which was another one of her
disasters
secretary
well I hope the fact Checkers are turned
up in turning up the volume and really
well when you're flying monkeys
that is absolutely
advocated we took in Libya
batteries that Gaddafi be taken out
after text the Google CEO business with
him one time but but the larger point he
says this constantly is the Lord
no made the agreement about when
Americans would leave Iraq Obama
and the only way that American troops
are going to stay in Iraq is to get an
agreement from the then Iraqi government
that would have protected our troops and
the Iraqi government would not this is a
nightmare let's talk about the question
you asked Lester the question you asked
is what do we do here in the United
States that's the most important part of
this how do we prevent attacks how do we
protect our people and I think we've got
to have an office for starters we are
looking for every scrap of information I
was so proud of law enforcement in New
York in Minnesota in New Jersey you know
they responded so quickly so
professionally
that occurred by rahami and they brought
him down and we may find out more
information because he is still alive
which may prove to be an intelligence
benefit so we've got to do everything we
can to vacuum up intelligence from
Europe
we're working with NATO the longest
military Alliance in the history of the
world to really turn our attention to
terrorism Donald Trump's faces
Muslims abroad Muslims at home when we
need to be cooperating with Muslim
nations and with the American Muslim
Community they're on the front lines
they can provide information to us that
we might not get anywhere else they need
to have close working cooperation with
law enforcement in these communities not
be alienated and pushed away uh as some
of uh Donald's rhetoric unfortunately
has led to Mr Mister well I'd have to
respond please respond
[Music]
the secretary said very strongly about
working with we've been working with
them for many years and we have the
greatest mess anyone's ever seen you
look at the Middle East it's a total
mess under your direction to a large
extent but you look at the Middle East
you started the Iran deal that's a
another Beauty where you have
ready to fall I mean they were doing so
badly they were choking on the sanctions
and now they're okay
major power at some point pretty soon
the way they're going but when you look
at NATO I was asked on a major show what
do you think of data and they have to
understand I'm a business person I did
really well but I have common sense and
I said well I'll tell you for those I
haven't given lots of thought to Nato
but two things number one
go to YouTube with their fair share
number two and that bothers me because
we should be yes we're defending them
and they should at least be paying us
what they're supposed to be paying by
treaty and contract and number two I
said and very strongly NATO could be
obsolete because and I was very strong
at this and it was actually covered very
accurately
for the New York Times to be honestly
just getting manhandled right now which
I'm surprised and I was very strong and
I said it numerous times
four months ago I read on the front page
of the Wall Street Journal that NATO is
opening up a major Terror Division and I
think that's great and I think we should
get because we pay approximately 73
percent of the cost of NATO it's a lot
of money
to protect other people but I'm all for
NATO but I said they have to focus on
terror also and they're going to do that
and that was believe me I'm sure I'm not
going to get credit for it but that was
largely because of what I was saying and
my criticism of NATO I think we have to
get NATO
to go into the Middle East with us in
addition to surrounding Nations and we
have to knock the hell out of Isis and
we have to do it fast when Isis formed
in this vacuum created by Barack Obama
and secretary Clinton
and believe me you were the ones
named the day they couldn't believe it
probably they're getting drunk believe
me you're getting
this is something that never should have
happened it should have never happened
now you're talking Jared's only on
halfway through his second beer he's
totally not playing Secretary of State
when it was a little infant
now it's an over three little infantry
she didn't kill it and you're gonna stop
them I don't think so Mr Trump you with
a lot of these are judgment questions
you had supported the war in Iraq before
The Invasion what makes your I did not
support the war in Iraq that is a
mainstream media oh someone said he just
delivered Hillary to us as next person
frankly I think the best four or five
answers here saying this is mainstream
media
it started going well and everything
went downhill he hasn't come back after
the birth certificate the war in Iraq
just not so hot
why was you is your job he's doing all
right but I think some of his answers
have been vague
Howard Stern very lightly first time
anyone's asked me that I said very long
he's on the ropes hard maybe who knows
essentially I then did an interview with
Neil Cavuto we talked about the economy
is more important I then spoke to Sean
Hannity which everybody refuses to call
Sean Hannity I had numerous
conversations with Sean
foreign
very strongly to me and other people
he's willing to say but nobody wants to
call him
I was against the war he said you used
to have fights with me because Sean was
in favor of the war and I understand
that site also not very much because we
should have never been there but nobody
calls Sean Hannity and then they did an
article in English
Okay and oh God we're going to lose a
selection
but they did an article which had me
totally against the war in Iraq and one
of your people are saying he's not doing
well whether it was before or right
after Trump was definitely because if
you read this article there's no doubt
but if somebody and I'll ask the Press
if somebody when he was doing that Sean
Hannity this was before the war started
he and I used to have arguments about
the war I said it's a terrible and a
stupid thing it's going to destabilize
why is Hillary with one else see what
it's done
don't ruin the good Hillary Clinton well
I have much better job judgment than she
does there's no question about that I
also have a much better temperament than
she has you know I have a much better
she spent let me tell you she spent
hundreds of millions of dollars on an
advertising you know they get Madison
Avenue into a room they put neighbor
temperament let's go after I think my
strongest asset
Maybe by far is my temperament I have a
winning temperament I know how to win
she does not have wait the AFL CIO the
other day
behind the blue screen I don't know who
you were talking to secretary Clinton
but you was totally out of control I
said
they're feeding me my talking lines
right now secretary Clinton she's loving
this okay
she's finding a rhythm
she just shook her bosoms did you see
that yeah
mentioned by Donald first Adam
you know NATO as a military Alliance has
something called Article Five and
basically it says this one is an attack
on all and you know the only time it's
ever been invoked after 9 11.
when the 28 nations of NATO
said that they would go to Afghanistan
with us to fight terrorism something
that they still are doing by our side
with respect to Iran when I became
Secretary of State Iran was weeks away
from having enough nuclear consensus is
he's not doing that they had mastered
the nuclear fuel cycle someone said I
don't think he's doing that bad it's
because you're drunk facilities they had
stocked them with centrifuges
whirling away
from them
at least one break here the Senate but
it wasn't enough so I spent a year and a
half putting together a coalition that
included in
China's the toughest
sanctions on Iran and we did drive them
to the negotiating table and my
successor John Kerry and President Obama
got a deal that put a lid on Iran's
nuclear program without firing a single
shot that's diplomacy that's Coalition
okay I'm going to mine it for people who
don't know the other day I saw Donald
saying that there were some Iranian
Sailors on a ship in the waters off of
Iran and they were taunting American
Sailors who were on a nearby ship he
said you know if they taunted our
Sailors I'd blow them out of the water
and start another War that's that would
not say judgment that is not the right
temperament to be commander-in-chief to
be
taunted and the worst part
Donald say has been about nuclear
weapons he has said repeatedly that he
didn't care if other nations got nuclear
weapons Japan South Korea even Saudi
Arabia it has been the policy of the
United States Democrats Japan that's my
Mickey Rooney
you could to reduce the proliferation of
nuclear weapons he even said well you
know if there were nuclear war in the
East Asia well you know that's fine you
know have a good time folks and in fact
his Cavalier attitude about nuclear
weapons is so deeply troubling that is
the number one threat we face in the
world and it becomes particularly
threatening if terrorists ever get their
hands on any nuclear material so a man
who can be provoked by a tweet should
not have his fingers anywhere yes let's
give Iran more stuff yeah I think anyone
with any sense about this should be
concerned's getting a little bit old I
must say listen it's a good one though I
would like well describes the problem
it's not an accurate one at all it's not
an accurate one so I just want to give a
lot of things and just to respond I
agree I will say people I'm seeing a lot
of trump supporters in the timeline
saying I wish you were doing better here
that he started off really strong we
both agreed but he's been fading off
would you say that's fair global warming
like you said it's a little sleepy
almost your president thinks nuclear is
the single greatest threat just to go
down the list we defend Japan we defend
Germany we defend South Korea there are
no commercials during the debate we
defend God they do not pay us but they
should be paying this because we are
providing tremendous service and we're
losing a fortune that's why we're losing
we're losing we lose on everything right
I say who makes these we lose on
everything well I say that it's very
possible that if they don't pay a fair
share because this isn't 40 years ago
where we could do what we're doing we
can't defend Japan a a behemoth selling
Us cars by the million we need to move
on but it's very important
help us out we're a country that owes 20
trillion dollars they have to help us
out as far as the nuclear is concerned I
agree it is the single Hawaii
which leads my next question is the last
segment here on the still on the subject
of securing America on nuclear weapons
President Obama reportedly considered
changing the nation's long-standing
policy on first use do you support the
current policy Mr Trump you have two
minutes on that well I have to say that
uh you know for what secretary Clinton
was saying about nuclear with Russia
she's very Cavalier in the way she talks
about various countries but Russia has
been expanding China and Mexico they
have the Mexico capability than we do we
have not been uh updating from the new
standpoint I looked the other night I
was seeing B-52s there old enough that
your your father your grandfather could
be flying them we are not we are not
keeping up with other countries I would
like everybody to end it just get rid of
it but I would certainly not do first
strike I think that once the nuclear
alternative happens
it's over at the same time we have to be
prepared I can't take anything off the
table because you look at some of these
countries you look at North Korea we're
doing nothing there China should solve
that problem for us sure they should go
into North Korea China is is totally
powerful as it relates to North Korea
and by the way another one powerful is
the worst deal I think I've ever seen
negotiated that you started as the Iran
deal Iran is one of their biggest
trading partners Iran has power over
North Korea and when they made that
horrible deal with Iran they should have
included the fact that they do something
with respect to North Korea and they
should have done something with respect
to Yemen and all these things
from Colorado somewhere from breckenrich
Brewery one of the great giveaways
that's my personal choice but of all
time including 400 million dollars in
cash nobody's ever seen that before that
turned out to be wrong it was actually
1.7 billion dollars in cash obviously I
guess for the hostages it certainly
looks that way so you say to yourself
why didn't they make the right deal this
is one of the worst deals ever made by
any country
in history the deal with Iran will lead
to nuclear problems all they have to do
is sit back 10 years
what can you do maybe Netanyahu the
other day believe me he is not a happy
camper all right I drink believe me you
have two minutes let me let me let me
start do you think Gary Johnson would
have shaking this up at all yet he would
have smoked himself silly and pissed the
stage before Hillary you are president
but I want to on behalf of myself and I
think on behalf of a majority of the
American people Hillary said it looks my
wife good Hillary said it looks like
Trump's going to vomit it's also
important that we look at the entire
Global situation
and Donald never tells you what he would
do would he have started a war would he
have bombed Iran if he's going to here
they go before my wife wants to know
what they do very very successful in
giving us access to Iranians
tell us what his alternative but it's
like his plan to defeat Isis
but the only secret is that he has no
plan so we need to be more precise in
how we talk about this all around the
world follow our presidential campaigns
so closely trying to get hints about
what we will do can they rely on us are
we going to lead the world someone says
are you going to vote Hillary strength
just because I've been saying that she's
been doing better
I intend to be listen if you want to if
you want someone who's gonna lie to you
of our country that people
at home and around the
world's gonna tell you what you want to
hear I think Trump started off really
strong I think he did really poorly in
the second half I think now it's abroad
or at home we cannot she's ahead and try
to destabilize the world to interfere
with American interests and security
what it looks like right now is he's
been dragging to deeper waters
very quickly but I go very quickly but I
will tell you that Hillary will tell you
to go to her website and read all about
how to defeat Isis which he could have
defeated by never having it you know get
going in the first place right now it's
getting tougher and tougher to defeat
them because they're in more and more
places more and more States more and
more Nations it's a big problem and as
far as Japan is concerned I want to help
all of our allies but we are losing
billions and billions of dollars we
cannot be the policeman of the world we
cannot protect countries all over the
world where they're not paying us what
we need we have just a few Fighters he
doesn't say that because she's got no
business ability we need heart we need a
lot of things but you have to have some
basic ability and sadly she doesn't have
that all of the things that she's
talking I don't know what he's talking
about
10 years let's say well she had great
power but they weren't taken care of and
if she ever wins this race they won't be
tested Trump this year secretary Clinton
became the first woman
she doesn't have quote a presidential
standing here right now what did you
mean by that she doesn't look she
doesn't have
I said she doesn't have the stamina and
I don't believe she does have the
stamina to be president of this country
you need tremendous stamina
wait a minute unless he asked me a
question did you ask me a question
you have to be able
to negotiate our trade deals you have to
be able to negotiate that's right with
Japan with Saudi Arabia I mean can you
imagine when we're defending Saudi
Arabia and with all of the money they
have we're defending them and they're
not paying all you have to do is speak
to him wait you have so many different
things you have to be able to do and I
don't believe that Hillary has the
stamina let's let her respond
well as soon as he travels to 112
countries and negotiates a peace deal a
cease-fire
a release of dissidents and opening of
New Opportunities and Nations around the
world or even spends 11 hours testifying
in front of a congressional committee he
can talk to me about stamina
the world
let me tell you Hillary has experience
but it's bad experience we have made so
many bad deals during the last time so
she's got experience that I agree but
it's bad bad experience
the grand deal that you're so in love
with where we gave them 150 billion
dollars back whether it's the Iran deal
whether it's uh anything you could you
almost can't name a good deal I agree
she's got experience but it's bad
experience and this country can't afford
to have another four years of that kind
of experience we are at the
he tried to switch from from looks to
stamina
but this is a man who has called women
pigs
sexism drink someone who has I'm almost
out of this beer pregnancy is an
inconvenience to employers it is women
don't deserve equal pay unless they do
as good a job
and one of the worst things he said was
about
make an intern woman in a beauty contest
he loves Beauty content it's a separate
phrase that's another thing around them
he called this woman Miss Piggy yeah
then he then that's funny Miss
housekeeping because she was Latina
Donald Trump
Machado and she has become a U.S citizen
and you can bet oh really she's going to
vote this November okay good let me just
tell you
just take 10 seconds Hillary is hitting
me with tremendous commercials some of
it said in entertainment some of it said
somebody who's been very vicious to me
Rosie O'Donnell I said very tough things
to her and I think everybody would agree
that she deserves it
I I was going to say
something extremely
rough
to Hillary to her family and I said to
myself
I can't do it I just can't do it what
it's inappropriate it's not nice
hundreds of millions of dollars on
negative
many of which are absolutely I was going
to be a big asses too and they're
misrepresentations
and I don't I I don't deserve that but
it's certainly not a nice thing that
she's done it's hundreds of millions of
ads and you're already nobody with this
I saw the polls come in today and with
all of that money the million dollars is
spent and I'm either winning or tied and
I've spent practically nothing one of
you it's too easy to get irritated over
the course of the night
are you willing to accept the outcome as
the will of the voters secretary Clinton
well I support our democracy and
sometimes you win sometimes you lose uh
but I certainly will support the outcome
of this election uh and I know Donald's
trying very hard to plant doubts about
it but I hope the people out there
understand this election is really up to
you it's not not about us so much as it
is about you and your families and the
kind of country and future you want to
do a post game wrap up get out and vote
as though your future depended on it
because I think it does Mr Trump very
quickly the same question will you
accept the outcome as the will of the
voters I want to make America great
again we are a nation that is seriously
troubled we're losing our jobs people
are pouring in to our country the other
day we were deporting 800 people and
perhaps they passed the wrong button
they pressed the wrong button or perhaps
worse than that it was corruption but
these people that we were going to
deport for good reason ended up becoming
citizens
ended up becoming citizens it was 800
and now it turns out it might be 18. I
don't even know
Hillary I want to make America great
again
all right well that is going to do it
for us that concludes our debate for
this evening a spirited one we covered a
lot of ground not everything as I
suspected we wouldn't uh would the next
Presidential debates are scheduled for
October 9th at Washington University in
St Louis and I won't be the 19th at the
University of Nevada
a reminder the vice presidential debate
is scheduled for October 4th at Longwood
University in Phoenix
thanks to Hillary Clinton and to Donald
Trump and to Hofstra University for
hosting us tonight good night everyone
we're ignoring it
stab I think first presidential debate
of this campaign season is in the record
books Hillary Clinton Donald Trump
taking questions are we still on Fox and
it's a win a little bit NBC and we see
them now shaking hands with the
moderator Lester look at her look at the
way she Waddles families as
tonight do you think either candidate
moved the needle in their directions
before I want to talk about the case all
right here so we got the we got you can
just have it playing in the background
here we can talk about it so we will
read your tweets here Jared you've got
my uh not good you've got my screen up
here yep uh uh he fell apart says
Patrick theis now just so you know you
can tell these people are
um
more conservative
hold on a second
he seems to try to bring the campaign
Relic he wasn't prepared properly this
is someone who's an ar15.com number so
okay so we're seeing this I'm just
trying to make sure that these aren't
from liberals uh trolling the the
Twitter page I'm at s Crowder he's at
not gay Jared what do you think of the
debate what's your read I think it's
pretty clear he had a great entrance
into it he had um he was he came out and
he was Zippy with his answers he was
pointed with his sticking to the issues
where she was going after the personal
stuff and then just completely did a
flip-flop second half if you actually a
little before the second half he kind of
started you have to write the whole
debate who do you give it to
as a whole
for someone who's watching the general
American public the one-third who don't
know where they're lining
gosh
I think Hillary had a little bit of edge
I think it's because she ended strong I
think if it would have flip-flopped the
order of it if he if he would end as
strong that's what people would be
remembering but I think people don't
remember kind of her the Trump clubs
yeah I think he started off strong then
I think he did really badly it started
going with the no-fly list to the
birther and then after that I would be
curious to see if they're going to give
you the total of time spoken yeah uh but
I bet you if you were to segment it the
second half Hillary probably outpaced
him like you know 60 40. I think it
started off it was even-handed he was
interrupting he was taking the floor and
I think by the end she was talking more
than he was he was talking confidently
toward the end but he was talking about
stuff I don't even know he's what it was
now I think what again you want
cheerleaders go over to one of the
cheerleader websites who are paid by
Trump or paid by Hillary were neither of
those
um obviously I want to see Hillary lose
I would much rather see Trump win at
this point
I think he started off really strong and
I think he faded did really poorly and
then it was kind of neutral
so you see this in fights a lot you see
people who come in they knock a bunch of
guys out in the first round and once
they're dragged into the second or third
round you've got you have people who are
able not prepared for a pace up they're
not prepared for it that's and you know
they call those the championship rounds
you know like in the UFC for example in
mixed martial arts you fight three
rounds and then Championship rounds are
five rounds so you have people who
fought their whole lives three rounds
and then when they fight in a title
fight they have to fight five five
minute rounds well Donald Trump has
never even fought three rounds for
talking about one-on-one debates so I
think he came in he was ready and I
think he treated it similar to when
there were 19 people on the stage yeah
and she wasn't ready for it and you see
kind of awkward timing and and you know
again I think she was ready for him to
go ad hominem right off the bat and he
didn't he didn't but then she lulled him
into it he's too easy to get frustrated
yeah and when he's off prompter and you
get him mad he gets back to what makes
him unlikable to the general public yeah
and I don't know why he would have gone
into the territory a couple things of
the the has the best Temperance for
the office I don't know why he would
have gone because he didn't do it in a
way that really like dispelled and shut
Hillary down before she can even respond
he just said I know I have a great
Temperance for for leadership and then
handed her the microphone yeah and she
had too much to unload on him on that
kind of thing that I mean that's been
the central point of time cyber security
that was when he didn't bring up the
emails he didn't bring up Benghazi so he
didn't put the the birther thing he
didn't put back on her no he didn't am I
a mistaken was that not was she wanted
not one of the first ones to bring that
up he should have he should have brought
it back on throwing it back on her and
kept on it he never even went there uh
he did I think at one point talked about
someone who worked with him I think he
made the point off on the outset and
then he rambled and that's the thing
like you know you've learned this kind
of been working with me and everyone who
writes the website and writing comedy we
go end on the punch and on the punch and
if you have to if you feel like there
are two or three punch lines
end the punch and tag it and then tag it
with another phrase another punchline
someone would do well to teach that to
him I know he's a showman and so maybe
he thinks he knows everything with that
but someone would it would serve him
well to learn how to hit a punch get in
make your point and move out I feel like
when he made a few good points he's
overstayed his welcome a little bit and
that's where some errors start to happen
that's where some mistakes start to
happen and then at that point you're
about 35 seconds in 10 seconds and you
made a good point but Hillary's able to
pick out the mistakes you made in the
last 35 40 seconds
so I would say this one um
I don't know if I would say it's a draw
I'm looking on Twitter here's what for
for Trump what would you say how did you
do in persuading people from the Hillary
camp or people from the left people from
The Bernie Camp so you think he did
anything
to win them over and in a way that was
not compromising
uh I'm looking back at the gun the
Second Amendment issues
the no-fly thing I don't think he's
gonna win anybody off of that he just
gave a lot of people away for that in my
opinion yeah I think he lost a lot of
people because here's the thing when you
hear a lot of people we talk about the
no-fly list right when you hear a lot of
people what's the main thing to say the
Supreme Court Heller versus DC that's a
big thing that Ted Cruz talked about
that uh the NRA talked about that in
their ads even when they supported Trump
saying listen it just takes a couple
Supreme Court Justice to change that
well guess what you could still have
something get before their get before
the court where okay no fly no buy and
if he's saying he would put someone in
there who would acquiesce to that yeah
well there goes the argument for a lot
of people including a lot of Democrats
by the way there are a lot of Democrats
I've said this they will part with that
issue on Hillary Clinton the gun issue
and a lot of them going man I just I'm a
Democrat I'm a union person uh I'm
pro-abortion I'm Pro big tax probate
government but I don't want Hillary
Clinton because of the gun issue yeah
and so they said so I'm gonna have to
vote for Donald Trump because he's going
to put someone in a supreme court and
if nothing nothing else he planted some
doubts people's minds of where he really
stands and what he really knows and
believes in that and I think it's one of
those things too where he doesn't stand
anything to gain from it and he's at the
end of the day you're not going to have
people I think turn around saying oh
well Donald Trump's pretty reasonable
that I might take a second you know what
it does it's uninformed uninformed and
he's not if he's trying to play the game
of he can't outgun control Hillary
Clinton he's not going to outdo her on
that realm like he's not gonna I think
Swoon people from saying Oh I thought he
was just a crazy gun guy no he's not no
I think he's you know I might be on
board now because he's he's willing to
concede that so I don't think he won any
points of that I think he just lost some
some real support I think you're right
and I think to people who are repo he
needs to appeal he needs more Republican
voters at this point he needs people to
understand that he's not going to get
any Democrat voters
um he needs Republican voters and some
of the undecided
so with that being said uh that shows
that he's uninformed because anybody you
can run a quick Google run a quick
Google search no fly or Terror watch
list famous people and you'll find
Stephen Hayes you'll find Ted Kennedy I
think Congressman Clyburn was on there
you can find a list of people who are
accidentally put on there and so anyone
who knows anything about the Second
Amendment anyone who knows anything
about politics to any degree knows that
that is BS as a matter of fact you'll
even hear uh even if you watch MSNBC a
lot of liberals saying well the no-fly
list doesn't it sounds good but it
doesn't really mean anything and you
know what if you're going to say well
let's use that as as a litmus test for
people not being able to maintain their
rights well you can serve them any right
with a no-fly list because there's no
there's there's no appeal it's just you
put on a list so even Liberals are like
that's not really accurate so for Donald
Trump to go with her on that he's going
to get he's going to get a lot a lot of
fire drawn on him because it would show
that he's somewhat uninformed in a
second I think if he was going to go
there on that if he was going to
continue see it a little bit there if he
was going to you know attempt to try to
draw the line and some some followers on
the other side he at least should have
laid out a plan of saying look there are
a lot of problems with this it needs to
be he never mentioned the words reform
and they'll fly a list right and
anywhere in there he mentioned that you
know maybe provide help people get off
if they're on but he didn't never talked
about even reforming it in a way that
made sense to get those people off he
just said basically we're gonna keep
doing what we're doing now yeah and you
know maybe give him a phone number I
think I think I think you lost some
ground on there
um here's the thing with Hillary Clinton
her biggest things when I hear it
her biggest mistakes are issues that I
don't like her on for example increasing
taxes for example her solution to Pander
they're both pandering to this blue
collar IDE you know there shouldn't
Detroit down they're both pandering to
sorry blue collar workers by telling
them they're going to keep their jobs
through either government tariffs or
she's saying through big government
taxes I don't care whether because
they're both fighting for the Rust Belt
hard they're fighting for the Rust Belt
hard and by the way the Rust Belt is
offset of Pennsylvania and Ohio it's
lost Illinois Michigan Wisconsin it's
just it's it's it's it's Union country
it's gimme country
um the things where I think she flubbed
again I have to watch this as someone
who's an American it's because I don't
like her policy but she did she did
pontificate she she did clarify her
policy as to what she would do with
taxes as to how she would uh bring jobs
here now it's bigger taxes of course I
don't believe it'll work uh this whole
Canadian type of Economics I don't agree
with her however
it's not an error where someone just
watching will say oh she doesn't she
sounds like she doesn't know what she's
talking about
again that's where the undecided the
Democrats will already agree with
they're an undecided people will look
and say well at least she's offering
something that sounds viable in contrast
to Trump my issues with Trump was that I
agree with him if you look at his tax
policy if you look at his website he
wasn't able to express that with her she
was able to express it and that's what I
didn't like about her but to the
undecided people that's a plus with him
he wasn't able to express it which I
wanted to hear because I agree more with
his policy does that make sense yeah
yeah I think uh
with her I think I think when you look
back on some of her greatest or her her
hardest hitting moments of the debate I
think we saw this before we had we have
some hints of this before in her some of
our rallies her greatest hardest hitting
moments were the ones where she just
said
you heard it let the audience laugh
exactly and I think I think Trump has
really got to watch the bombs that was I
think also on the temperance thing he
went there didn't provide a way didn't
cut her off of the pass he opened the
door wide open to that attack
um she has too many talking points on
that she has too many things I mean if
you watch any at Hillary ad that's all
it's a good point because him saying
well you know why don't you know you
can't blame me for everything well why
don't wait you know it's a clever thing
people laugh that's different right
because that's a punch line and a laugh
is very different from someone providing
no punch line and going look at the
clown Donald Trump folks again now again
if you're not going to like to hear this
but that's the general public that
audience it's let's say it's split let's
say it's stacked in her favor however
you don't get to Simply say
this is what he said and say nothing
with people laughing unless it was
absurd enough to the point where people
think it's silly so you need to take the
blinders off I don't think either had a
great performance I I guess I would kind
of call it a wash I think you're gonna
see The Drudge poll and it will say
Donald Trump won by 100 margin I think
huffpo will say Hillary Clinton won by
100 margin I think if you look at people
who still haven't decided I would think
maybe a 55 45 60 40 for Hillary if only
I think they probably had their moments
but hers came later in the debate and
those just like in sports they're scored
more heavily yeah I think you're right
that's my take on it but you know what
there are two more debates and uh
gosh here's a question for you what does
Trump have to learn going into the next
one to be better you know I don't know
that he can ironically can he adapt fast
enough ironically enough you know what
he lacked this debate this debate
specifically was stamina
he faded and he got tired he started off
strong and he he he finished really slow
he was lagging so he needs to again I
could be wrong here I mean if Charles
Krauthammer gets it wrong 60 of the time
I probably don't have a shot I think he
needs to Pace himself
he needs to prepare a little bit more
and he needs to understand that Hillary
Clinton because she's a robot demon
woman doesn't get flustered and she's
okay with personal attacks she's okay
weathering the storm as long as she can
get her get her shots in later yeah so I
think most importantly I ironically
enough the lady with pneumonia and
likely uh AIDS and cancer uh out
conditioned him she had better condition
she had better debate conditioning than
him tonight yeah that's that's
experiencing as well as something you
can't really
I don't know how you would even prepare
for that really yeah I'm just trying to
see this from people who haven't decided
yet
um
hopefully that provides some insight to
people because a lot of people can't
can't get past their own point of view
with that no Trump won no Hillary
Hillary needs a sexist you know you
don't want to be the conservative
version of Trump's sexist no matter what
he says you don't want to be the
conservative version of Hillary's a liar
you need to look at it you don't do
yourself any favors by lying to yourself
when it started off though I do feel
like it started off so strong for him
but I feel like that was for 30 of the
time and then for 70 of the time she was
better but she didn't have any of those
really strong pops she didn't and when
he did kind of perk up with some life
usually like if you're to just garble
the group The Language he was saying
this the words he was speaking the
energy was back but when you once you
put the English back in it's like where
is he going with this I'm not sure what
he's talking about he's just trying to
go off on a tangent just to get his
minutes in and I don't think because I
don't think he was prepared enough to
give a response to what she was talking
about previously
um that's true but I think here's the
thing I think that Trump has gone from I
think a lot of people are wanting to
give this to him they're wanting him to
win because they are tired of the
establishment of the politicians like
Hillary Clinton they don't like her they
want her to lose
uh he didn't quite hand her that loss
tonight no if we're looking if we're
trying to look at this objectively
people are lined up and ready for Donald
Trump to win people who aren't already
you know make America great again
um people are lined up for someone other
than Hillary I don't think Donald Trump
served her the loss that he needed
tonight so I think after this I think
it's still in play
um I think it's anybody's game and I
think he needs to get better debate
conditioning I think he needs to
understand that she can weather the
storm and she can keep her Pace up and
he needs to be able to do that I think
that will be the biggest Factor look in
future debates to see
he's not going to be able to come on
that strong so the next debate if we go
oh okay he's not coming out guns blaze
in the first 30 minutes you need the
fourth quarter Trump yep you need the
fourth quarter Trump yep we didn't see
the sign so uh that's my read on it um
I don't know you can tweet me at s
Crowder or not gay Jared we're going to
get a highlight reel up on YouTube or
something yeah tomorrow okay so this
will get up on YouTube Somewhere
hopefully with not some kind of
copyright thing and uh
uh tweet us let us know what you thought
and uh we are here to serve and to
please don't get any ideas this doesn't
mean daily we are not making an
announcement in late October and or
November we're not building a new studio
we are not going daily so hashtag never
daily make sure you tell your friends
thank you for being with us and uh
hydrate get your electrolytes if you
were playing the drinking game we'll see
you Thursday for the election with
Andrew Bogut Andrew Bogut
Andrew Bogut Andrew Bogut and either uh
we don't know Paul Joseph Watson or Ben
Shapiro on this week so big show Andrew
Bogut NBL star All-Star uh NBA champion
champion so there you go Andrew go good
so big show this week we will see you
Thursday tell your friends
um otherwise
you're an anti-semite and racist and
sexist and transphobe sounds fair to me
oh Dan Rather looks rough